[Music]
in May of backlash news all chutes
submitted by hey [ __ ] hey a beauty guru
may be getting sued over a video of her
trashing a local makeup artist a local
makeup thrashing like talking [ __ ] oh
yeah I'm going on it so this you knew
about this I do because I feel okay fair
yes I'll try - a it very fairly and then
I'll say my opinion I think let's do it
okay youtuber name is Marge just so you
guys have a face - I'm I don't want me
to say okay so her name is Maura but her
actual name was many of us she's four -
whele she's so she's like female right
and so she there's this like YouTube
videos called like worst rated going to
the war sory to makeup artists we're
going to the worst rated yeah nail salon
tell ya and so like people have these
horrible experiences and then they film
it put it online
and then people watch it and it's funny
right so she went to the worst rated
makeup artist in Las Vegas who she's
from LA but I think she just was in town
she went there and she filmed in the
bathroom she filmed the makeup brushes
on the outside of the location she fit
like she drove by it was like a red and
red a yellow building so it looked very
like you could see like a fire yeah and
so she blurred out the faces but people
were still able to find out who it was
and where it was the lowest-rated in
Vegas right Google ish they found out
because the daughter of the makeup
artist right so the daughter of the
makeup artist found the video and they
she tweet it out and she was like hey
just so you know that's everything so
many details okay okay um well if I see
appointment before that though this is
what she looked like
after that looks like Costco yeah this
is the makeup this year but the building
behind her it looks like Costco yeah
when the video looks pretty good but she
also posted this as a thumbnail so this
is oh she lied that she says that she
got a skin infection after the romba
make her she needed to cause more drama
that course got a notepad oh oh and then
also during the video she was doing
these like little jabs like casually
gaining a face infection in white text
out the video yeah I'm saying like like
the makeup artist was spraying her face
at one point she's like what tiny sound
let's tell Manila yeah and she didn't
know she was being recorded by the way
yeah and then um so this was the
daughter this is a daughter so the
daughter said wasn't going to post this
cuz we don't want the sympathy but she
needs to know you judge my mom civility
she put a veil ability but I think she
might ability no it was availability oh
you judge my mom's availability but the
reason she has that availability is to
take care of her
17 year old daughter with special needs
because in the video she was saying that
she had to go to the salon two days like
the first day was to try to get an
appointment but then that the makeup
artist only worked from Monday through
Friday but then she's like it's makeup
like aren't there events on the weekends
I won't to work on the weekend so she
was like kind of jabbing at that and
then she also said that they made an
appointment for 12:00
but then the salon said oh no it was
4:11 she was here waiting for you but
you never came in sure she left
since she had to make an appointment
again because they kept telling her you
want to make a deposit for your thing
and she didn't put a deposit down did it
so then now what the daughter said was
hello I know this person who did your
makeup and we reviewed this video this
was all a setup and you know it we went
over there I mean we went over what
happened with the makeup artist and she
let you know that she is not an expert
on fantasy makeup which is what you
presented to her all of the makeup that
she uses is professional cause she was
claiming that it was a friend a
professional makeup and from a brand
made by the school that she got
certified out which is Chino Hills
California parenthesis including the
primer that you lied about burning you
because she said that in the video she
showed you the brands but you seemed to
not have remembered that since you
rushed her work constantly saying that
you were in a hurry to leave so that she
could not finish like you mentioned
there are trying to get her to [ __ ] up
yeah yeah like you mentioned there are
cameras in the salon and we have the
footage of what actually happened during
your visit the makeup artist repeatedly
told you to put your phone down because
you were disruptive disrupting the
process making it harder for her to do
your makeup all of her products are
sanitized and she throws his mop bucket
there with dirty ice water and she joked
in the video
that she used that to clean the makeup
brushes so she said and she never used
the mop bucket as a place to clean the
makeup brushes first of all that is
incredibly disgusting and anyone with
the brain would know to never do that
and it's a horrible
I mean it's alive now you came up with
to make your video your horrible video
more even more attending these bit more
interesting you lied to all your
followers with the comments you made
about Salmonella infested and
bacteria-infested and even showed her
untidy workspace which was due to your
you rushing her so that she could not
organize everything you planned you
planned out everything to make it seem
like what the artist did was terrible
came in with a plan to attack the salon
and convince your viewers that you were
a victim it's sad
that as a Latina you would come into a
salon that is latina owned and ran so
that you can come tear them down in
order to get views and likes while this
store may not be the high-end salons you
feel like you belong to this is a salon
for the middle to lower class and is
respected in the community know that
this is defamation of character and for
the salon you will be hearing from us
again it is a straight form of
defamation and not only that it's plaid
yeah and if they could prove that which
I think they have a lot of good evidence
for she's gonna give didn't the
community give her love stars though I'm
just I'm just that's what I'm wondering
they didn't come in here to give what
give this along I actually looked into
this because I was like let me find out
I wanted to cheer for the youtuber like
she's latina like I really wanted her to
not be a dick you know but I looked up
the salon and I looked at the reviews
and there is like literally not that
many bad reviews so is it on Yelp it is
on Yelp and they're like the makeup
artist she actually went to is never
mentioned anywhere on yummy stars uh it
was I mean it's not even rated a lot
because I feel like a lot of low-income
not rated Yelp
yeah they don't even have a Yelp because
they're low rated facilities you know so
I think that she probably just looked up
a salon that was like in the hood you
know she went and she got the treatment
like any other hood salon would give her
and then she just exposed whatever she
could
a lot of yelp is paid for so uh uh so
it's like yeah oh yeah oh yeah there's
been documentaries about I called like
one of them is called like the red mafia
or something but it's about how yellow
dam shakes down business owners in order
to get money from them to push them up
in the ratings and like never gonna give
you money and to squelch the bad reviews
sort of like flushes the bad reviews and
has good reviews you people a lot of
people game Yelp right so yeah there's
something to be said for what is
actually the lowest rated what is
actually the best rating yeah [ __ ] like
that something either so the daughter
added a little bit more and said I know
you're trying to ruin what pays the roof
over my sister's head her doctor's
appointments and her medicine that keeps
her alive oh and now mm-hmm
you should be ashamed she is her
full-time job and she includes photos of
her and her sisters did an apology video
where you Selena shirt yeah so she's
exactly play emphasize that [ __ ] because
she was calculated that's so fake was
there nice music and everything no there
was no music and noise okay how you did
apology video but but she hasn't taken
down the original video because what the
family is saying like we just want you
to take down the show because literally
you're staying so many people are
talking bad about us and my mom Debbie
they're still up it's a fake apology
there's a lawyer that's gonna contact
them and help them out I hope some
people should run ads on their apology
videos I actually think I think so too I
think it's [ __ ] stupid yes so Mara
was saying in this apology video that
she cannot apologize for the truth that
she did say sorry for bringing the
family pain as she never intention to
purposely hurt anyone and that she
really did get a face and a skin
infection because people were pointing
out like in the video in the original
video at the end of it she says I got an
infection and like you see a whole bunch
of like marks on her face and then she
showed the medicine that she had and
some people were commenting how the
actual tube it looked like you zoom up
like I look
pretty used up and so people are saying
like dude those [ __ ] tubes last
forever and you this was like in less
than a week's time that she used it so
they're like that's kind of fishy yeah
and also some people were saying like
that's the exact sentiment same
medication that I used for my eczema
like is she lying about that yeah so but
then in her apology video she showed a
doctor's note a prescription or like the
fact that she bought that meh it was on
the IE so that's what's happening
damn I mean I do like exposing bad
businesses but I also know that people
on YouTube do crazy [ __ ] just to get
clout yeah and I think there's a
difference between exposing a bad
business and where you generally had a
bad experience and seeking to find like
the lowest income like service you can
just to like get like views that's
[ __ ] up like if you have to go all the
way to do that like you're obviously not
that entertaining [ __ ] because like it
you're staying within your range like
why don't you like go to the worst rated
and [ __ ] Beverly Hills or you don't I
mean like why do you go to these
low-income places and try to mess with
the people like yeah the make up friend
she was using what's not like urban
decay it was nothing like super
expensive because that makeup artist
obviously can afford it and that people
going there aren't trying to get their
makeup done like a professional on
YouTube would it wasn't even like really
low rated cuz when it's really low rated
on Yelp you see the reviews and they're
like they were mean to me and they were
this to me and like I was like oh [ __ ]
that'd be like the part that kind of
irked me in her apology video is she was
saying like I was poor oh yeah I ain't
know what that's like so yeah I'm not
trying to say that you know like my life
is over here whatever the [ __ ] she said
but that part I was just like if you
knew you would have taken that [ __ ] down
because the whole thing is like a Oh
[ __ ] has that feeling of ill I can't
believe I'm in this place why yeah
that's weird
yeah that's really weird oh my god
they're doing this and all that they
have security cameras because there was
this trendle where people were staying
at the worst rated hotels yeah he's
doing and I think yeah you and some of
the hotels are [ __ ] hilarious
is how [ __ ] bad it's like it's crazy
and you can see with your eyes you don't
need words on the street true true and I
think there's a difference between
saying like oh she [ __ ] up my makeup
she was just so bad at it and saying
like oh this is disgusting like I can't
believe I'm [ __ ] standing in here and
there's some mail and everywhere like
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up smoking it yeah I
just feel better the big person taking
boiling like the little one
you know like obviously has a big
channel looking for negative shits
looking for a tiny ass little like
poorly rated yeah I did to make
entertainment out of it you could have
saved her ass if she went to the lowest
rated one goes in there and goes oh [ __ ]
actually she's not using a brown I've
ever seen but it's actually coming out
pretty fine the silver lining she's
rushing me but oh [ __ ] while you're the
better a better vlogger you know the
machine I did it take pallet to do that
[ __ ] apology she said that you know mate
[ __ ] she was like I went to I went to
the worst worried worst rated nail salon
and now that's actually my daily salon
did she put that in a video before she
bashed it cause I'm not gonna give you
yes right she should have gone to the
world's worst rated uber driver or
something he pulls up and he's like are
you ready to go yeah I just think the
worst thing is that she's not taking it
down because obviously people are still
watching it and they're still like
bashing on this poor [ __ ] lady who
probably paid her little pennies to go
to this [ __ ] cosmetology school and
like it's just not fair
yeah I think it would be fair if the
lady was really mean yeah you think
there's something to like complaining
about somebody not working weekends and
then being like you are attacking me for
taking care of my special needs daughter
is a little like whoa bro [ __ ] I just
said you should work look I just said
why aren't you guys open on the weekends
I don't know one little ripe